hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 2020
candidates tournaments we are in round
number four had the day off yesterday we
were back in the next three days for
three more rounds our competitors today
why it's gonna be played by MVL he is at
the top of the standings with two draws
in one win his win came against England
his opponent today
Alexander Ganesha he has three draws so
he's half a point behind the leaders in
the tournament has find himself in a lot
of time trouble over the past few games
seems to spend a lot of time on some
moves that many of the commentators have
said should not take that long so that's
some time crunch very difficult to have
a victory when you always are against
the clock but as managed to come out
with the draw on each of the first three
games will be looking to improve upon
his performance in in this game playing
the black pieces though against in the L
so we're going to get in to the game
here with NBL starting with E 4 E 5 men
f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 so going to
the right Lopez and then Knight f6
Castle on the King side so this is the
Birdland offense which we see most
common in the RAI Lopes at the highest
level Knight takes here on e4 pawn up to
d4 so a couple different variations that
y can go down this seems to be one of
the more common variations that we've
seen that comes back to a d6 not
necessarily my favorite variation in the
Berlin defense the main reason is after
Bishop takes and the pawn takes here and
pawn to e5 many of these are almost
forced there's not a lot of other good
variations that either side has Knight
comes down here to f5 and then the Queen
comes off the board and this tends to be
a draw game both sides still have a lot
of opportunity to come up with an
advantage but Queen's come off the board
one of the minor pieces no sides really
have a control of the center of the
board it's very difficult for either
side to gain the upper hand
and in this particular variation in the
Berlin defense both sides continue on
NBL h3 then King here to e8 both sides
starting to get more two pieces involved
into the game Knight to c6 upon down
here h5 Bishop f4 opening up the door
for the rook to swing over into the
center of the board also protecting the
pawn here on e5 Bishop to e7 rook to d1
as we talked about Bishop to e6 game
light squared Bishop involved opening up
for the rook to swing over here to d8 at
some point as well the bishop is
attacking the pawn but the knight is
protecting it here on a 2 nice swings up
to g5 and then rook down here to h6 so
this chick is fine giving up his Bishop
pair doesn't seem like he once to really
hold on to that because he's just
inviting him be able to take here on e6
and be honest heads not to do that first
wings this rook over here to e1 and then
Bishop down to b4 now on the game we see
a 3 to me I'm not the biggest fan of
that because you're just opening up the
door for Bishop takes pawn recaptures
and then you have this awkward double
pawn here on the C file it's fine if
black has it because you have the
connecting pawn here on the B file you
can always take back here at some points
and not have double pawns but the way
it's set up right now it's not that
great for for white eventually blacks
gonna be able to attack this and
potentially go up upon a material he had
another option instead of a three-year
could just play Knight to e4 if he's not
gonna take the bishop what you already
had the opportunity for the Knight to e4
makes a lot of sense that's defending
the knight right here it's also having a
discovered attack against this rook here
on h6 o may force black to move this but
if the bishop does take you know he
could always take this this rook up here
but if he decides yeah I don't want you
to take my rook he could always just
swing back over here this Knight still
on a good square here it doesn't have to
worry about double pawns on the C fob
but in the game we do see the pond come
here to a3 Bishop takes pawn recaptures
and then h4 MBL pushes forward with a g4
and then we see on pasand if you're not
familiar thumb passant
when you know black in this case is on
the fourth-ranked here and white moves
up two squares black has one move in one
move only to capture in a really weird
way and that is diagonal here to g3 if
he doesn't he doesn't have another
opportunity after this but he decides to
go and do that and BL recaptures here on
a g3 that comes up to e7
and then we see h4 so why doing a good
job when your opponent has one
particular Bishop you want to put your
material on the other colors meaning
this is the light square bishop so in DL
putting most of his pawns it's a little
more difficult right now with these
double pawns here but the rest of his
pawns on dark squares pretty much makes
this bishop a lot less useful in the
game now we see Knight coming down here
to d5 attacking both the bishop and the
pawn here on c3 busy comes back here to
c1 at that for sure we would see Bishop
down to D - yes it's attacking both the
bishop and upon but the bishop comes our
swing back here to D to protect this
pawn and be able to sides instead to
bring his Bishop back here to c1 only
reason he would do that is he has a plan
to get back some material because he's
giving up a pawn right now and Alexander
Gershon Utley has the upper hand in this
position rook here to d3 attacking the
knight and that comes back here to a4
rook to f3 attacking the square here on
f7 preparing to double barrel with his
rook over here to f1 with his bishop on
e6 at least for the time being doing a
job of holding on to this now mvo could
also take here on e6 at some point that
could open up for when the pawn
recaptures or depending on how the rook
recaptures if there's two rooks here on
the F file they could really start to
chip away at this f7 square so instead
we see Alexander who should bring his
bishop here to d5 attacking the rook and
still protecting the f7 square while
getting out of harm's way of the night
that could take it here on e6 rooks
wings up here to f4 just been proving
the position a little bit still
preparing for the work to come over here
but also attacking the knight
here on a four-night swings back to b6
rook to f1 as we talked about rook to g6
not really gonna be doing too much as
far as attacking the knight but just
wants to be there in case the knight
moves then it can have a free square to
come down take the pawn here on a g3
checking the king so just really taking
away some of the threats that white has
moving the Knights rook to f5 this is a
discovered attack at some point if the
pawn ever comes here to e6 can always
attack this Bishop so just something to
keep in mind bishop immediately gets out
of the way and that is Bishop here to c4
still defending the pawn now attacking
the rook here on f1 rook to e1 you have
this pawn here on fee 5 it seems to be
the biggest threat that white has going
in the game so wants to have protection
behind that so we can start pushing up
the board here King to e7 recognizing
that once to start stopping some of the
the pushing that's going on also wants
to allow his rook on 8th if it wants to
swing over to attack on the King side it
has that option as well so why it's
still down upon the material decides to
start pushing a little bit more see if
he can find a weakness and black setup
and potentially get some of that
material back plays aged 5 and then rook
over here to h6 then pushes g4 here and
then we see Brooke come back here to h8
pawn to a4 Knight takes here on a4 and
then Bishop to a3 check now this is an
interesting position because whites now
giving up two pawns you can see Black
has six pawns to whites four pawns here
but the bishop on a3 is first gonna be
able to get some material back because
after pawn to c5 yes it is protected by
this night here on a4 but it does set up
for this move here of e6
now this pawn is protected both by the
knight and the rook here on a one but it
also opens up the door for the bishop to
take here on c5 this rook is protecting
this pawn now we see f6
here and then the Bishop's gonna take
here check rook to or Knight takes here
on c5 we're gonna swing over and capture
and says yeah if you want to take my
material that's fine pawn takes rook
comes up here to c7 is able to take that
pawn check and is also gonna prepare to
come down and take this bishop here on
c4 so now both sides are equal in
material but you can also see that black
has these awkward double pawns on the G
file so in a sense why it's a little bit
better off so white going all the way
down from one pond to equal in material
but kind of up on once he can capture
this myth's here on part of the reason
for this is the oxen or goose chick is
starting to go down on time we are
approaching that 40 move mark but if you
look at this time it just does not
nearly have as much as in DL it doesn't
seem to be making the precise moves that
he did at the beginning of the game when
he had a slight advantage
so from here pawn down to a5 work over
here to d1 check rook to e4 just trying
to hold down this central pawn here pass
pawn that wants to be pushing forward
this is his main path to victory here
rook over here to d8 we see rook to b1
why it's not looking to exchange right
away still for likes he has an
opportunity to win this game doesn't
want to give up all his material here
rook to b8 Black's definitely in defense
mode trying to hold on as he has for the
first three rounds of the tournament for
a draw here rook to b5 and then we see
black start to push on the Queen side
the board with a four rook takes here on
a g5 as we talked about now white is up
a pawn in material rook to g8 here pawn
to h6 we do see an exchange right here
now both sides are equal in material
rook takes on a4 you can see
yes whites up but it's still gonna be
very difficult to to get a victory now
pawn to h5 then King starts to get
involved into the game rook takes here
on a g4 and this is also a great little
outpost here that's you know once we
take here you could take with this pawn
could take with his rook here decides
take with his rook keep his pawn here on
the h-file is far away from the king as
he can so the King can't easily swing
and capture that pawn we do see that the
pawn recapture there's just no way
around this and from here King takes on
e6 King takes here and then this is a
drawn game there's just no way for
either side to win this both sides are
gonna be moving over to the Queen side
of the board but at the end of the day
it would be very difficult for either
side to lose this they tried everything
in their power to go to an endgame where
they had a slight advantage but there is
just no way to to win from here so after
all the pieces which we rarely see in a
chess game most players are going to
offer a draw well before this but we get
to a point where there's only Kings on
the board and that is a drunk game so
NBL still at the top they were all draws
today so for matches and all drawls NBL
still sits at the top there's a
three-way tie with with the chess
players and then right behind that half
a point behind and that is Alexander
district still undefeated in the
tournament but remember doesn't that
matter if you were undefeated that does
not mean you were going to win the
tournament so he's gonna be looking to
get his first win tomorrow because so
far it's been all draws hopefully he can
do better with his time played really
well at the beginning of the game and
the Berlin defense you don't always see
black have a advantage and that's
exactly what he did was up upon and
material I had a pretty good game going
from middle to the endgame but started
to run out of time
I think miscalculated in a few areas and
let MVL back into it almost gave him V L
an opportunity to win the game but he
did correctly defend and ended up with a
drawl so almost kind of congratulations
to district for getting the job it was
still an exciting game berlin defense
you never know what you're gonna see we
see many times it's it's a drone game
but we did see both sides have a small
chance but thank you guys so much for
watching
round number four hopefully everyone is
safe out there and we will be back
tomorrow
covering round number five
the 20/20 Canada's tournament